hey you guys time once again for the
flickers of fear movie review show
so the movie we're talking about today
uh is a 2020 film called my heart can't
beat unless you tell it to
now this movie uh was actually supposed
to come out i think it was supposed to
premiere actually at the tribeca film
festival
but obviously because that was i think
it was april 2020 uh and that got
cancelled so what ended up happening
with the movie was that dark sky films
ended up picking it up and then in the
autumn of 2020
released it i don't know if they did
they might have done like a limited
theatrical release but probably not
since it was fall of 2020 and it
actually turned up on a bunch of
different streaming services uh shutter
has it as of this recording amazon prime
has it for free as of this recording i
believe 2b has it as well so it's very
very easy to see
so this movie is the
premiere or the uh feature length debut
rather of a director named jonathan
quartus
i don't really remember why in
particular this movie kind of like
caught my eye or caught my interest i
think it was because like when i was
scrolling through the newer movies i
think it was on shutter
that i don't know i just really liked
the title of it it sounded like a really
cool uh title and also it seemed to have
like pretty high reviews like four and
five skulls i didn't really read a lot
of the reviews but you can see like the
little skull rating or whatever
and it seemed to have a lot of really
good ratings so i went into this
watching it the other day
literally knowing nothing about it i did
all i knew was the title and the fact
that it got decent reviews uh i didn't
even read a synopsis or anything like
that
now i will say
that i think it's actually better going
into the movie not knowing anything
about it um but obviously i'm not gonna
be able to discuss it with you guys if
that was the case so i'm not gonna spoil
the end or anything like that but
you do kind of have to to you know
discuss this movie in in any way shape
or form you will have to like say what
kind of movie it is and do like maybe
some kind of like mild spoilers i guess
i don't even know if i'd call it
spoilers but because i've seen some
other i haven't seen the trailer for
this so i don't know if the trailer like
spoils what kind of movie it is uh but i
know that some of the reviews i saw did
in the sense that they're saying like
what subgenre it is let me say it that
way but
i will say that if you want to watch
this film
uh it's just one thing okay it's um kind
of
a slow burn uh it's like a family drama
but it is i don't know if i'd call it
supernatural but i don't know but if you
like kind of slow burn family dramas
that also have like some horror elements
to it then you would probably like this
otherwise it's not like action-packed
it's not really a monster movie or
anything like that but like i said it's
better going into it not knowing
anything about it
so from the very very first scene of
this film you're kind of like sucked in
and like i said i didn't know anything
about this so i just went into it
completely blind and i was just kind of
like huh what do we got going on here
type thing
so the opening scene is like there's a
homeless man
and he's got his shopping cart there and
stuff like that and he's kind of like
rummaging through the dumpster like
looking for food or looking for some
stuff he can sell or whatever
and then this pickup truck like pulls up
in the alley next to him
so the driver of this pickup truck uh
whose name we later discover is dwight
he actually offers the homeless man like
some food like he gets him a burger
and uh you're led to believe that he
tells them he's like hey i'll give you a
ride to this shelter that i know about
and you can get some sleep for the night
or whatever
um you know the homeless man is
obviously very wary saying like hey i'm
not gonna suck your dick or anything
like that but dwight's like no that
isn't what this is now you know that
it's probably something like nefarious
you're just not entirely sure what's
going on
so they get to this kind of remote i
don't know if it's remote but it's like
a kind of a suburban looking kid's a
little bit shabby looking suburban house
and the homeless man uh very you know
she basically just says uh this doesn't
look like a shelter you know
as you would
and uh he's like it looks like a house
and he's like yeah it used to be says
dwight
so then the homeless man gets out like
to go into the house and dwight comes up
behind him and clobbers him on the head
with a baseball bat
at which point
he takes uh the homeless he drags the
homeless man inside and then you see
that dwight and then there's this other
woman in the house this very very thin
woman with long hair dwight kind of like
maneuvers the the dude's like limp body
onto the table like in the kitchen
and the woman like cuts his throat and
drains all of his blood out so as i said
this is just like the opening scene of
the movie and i'm like all right you got
my attention
uh and as i said i had no idea what was
going on
now this is where the mild spoiler kind
of [ __ ] gets into the thing because i
didn't know this going in but uh and i
think it's better that you don't but if
you still want to like listen to it then
that's up to you
so what we subsequently learn
is that dwight and this other woman who
is actually his sister jessie
they have this thing going where they
every few days i guess um they go out
and they pick up somebody usually like a
homeless person or a sex worker a
drifter of some kind you know just kind
of society's cast offs if you want to
put it that way so they go and kidnap
one of those kind of people
and then they bring them back to the
house and kill them and drain all their
blood
and they feed
this blood to their
very gentle and childlike younger
brother thomas
so
as you may have surmised uh my heart
can't beat until you unless you tell it
to
is essentially a vampire movie although
they never say the word vampire
this is kind of like and as i said it
doesn't really have a lot of
supernatural elements to it although
thomas does seem to have
you know he seems to survive uh solely
on blood um if he goes out in the sun
like he burns stuff like that so but
it's but it's very very grounded in
reality so this is much more a vampire
movie
more like in the vein of let the right
one in or martin uh the george romero
movie something like that so it's not
really like a classical vampire movie or
maybe like the addiction that movie from
when was that the 90s that lily taylor
was in where it's just kind of like i
don't say it's using vampirism as a
metaphor because thomas is actually does
seem to be a vampire uh just not kind of
like supernatural but he does have some
like vampiric
uh traits but it's kind of using
thomas's vampirism in a way of like this
is it's almost like a metaphor uh for
exploring
dealing with somebody like caring for
somebody that has essentially a terminal
illness
and the sacrifices that you make along
the way like to keep that person alive
so that's kind of like what the
underlying thing of this uh movie
actually is like all of the sacrifices
that you know the loved ones of uh these
patients like uh do on their loved ones
behalf
so the movie doesn't actually specify uh
how long thomas has been this way you're
led to believe just from a lot of
context clues i guess i don't think it's
been his whole life i don't think he was
born like that or anything like that
they don't as i said they don't call him
a vampire they just say he's sick and
that he has a disease and that's like
the only way that they can cure it
uh they also don't the movie also
doesn't uh specify what happened to
the siblings parents you know you could
maybe i kind of like pictured that maybe
the parents had fed themselves to thomas
or something like that at some point in
the past but this is not uh referred to
now jessie uh she actually also works as
a waitress like at a at a diner in this
little bitty town
i think this was shot in salt lake city
by the way in utah
uh so she works as a waitress kind of
make ends meet
and she seems like she's kind of i don't
want to say she runs the household with
like an iron fist or anything but she's
kind of like the boss i mean she's the
one that sort of like you know
reinforces like uh all the rules
so
she homeschools thomas now thomas i'm
not they don't really tell you how old
he is he appears to be maybe 17 18 maybe
even his early 20s but the way he acts
is a lot more childlike so that's what i
mean so you're led to believe that
thomas has been sheltered for a very
very long time so i don't i don't think
the implication is that he was born a
vampire or maybe he was maybe he was
born with this disease i'm not really
sure that you know is akin to vampirism
it doesn't really matter but he is very
very sheltered and very childlike
so
you know he he must have been
uh closed in for a really long time so
jesse never lets him go outside it
appears that the
that the siblings the older siblings
kind of keep a schedule
where they're kind of up all night with
him sort of because he can't go out in
the daytime because you're let for a
little while when i was watching it i
was kind of thinking well is he really
like a vampire can he could he actually
go outside in the daytime and he'd be
fine but there is one point where he
actually kind of like opens the door and
like puts his arm outside and his arm
like blisters and burns so it does
appear that um that he can't go outside
in the daytime now he can go outside at
night apparently because he does kind of
do that but jessie
i guess because she's just like afraid
of what will happen to him uh doesn't
even really like him to go outside at
all
um although you know his brother dwight
will take him outside at night sometimes
and just kind of let him stand in the
yard or whatever just so he's not like
cooped up in this sort of depressing
house all the time
now uh so jessie like i said she's the
one that kind of enforces the rules
dwight is kind of the guy
that has to go out
and
collect uh the victims
and so he does that like and he's really
uh having a hard time with it so i guess
he's been doing it for a while and it's
just really starting to wear on him uh
and they kind of show him you know
picking up the people and then like
after they get killed you know he buries
them and then they you know take their
clothes like he washes all their clothes
very meticulously folds them and then
takes them and sells them like at thrift
stores and stuff so that's kind of like
the routine that they've had going but
as i said you can tell that dwight is
really getting to a point where he just
can't live with himself anymore he can't
do this anymore because he's very
isolated as well
it seems that his only kind of like
outlet is he goes and visits this sex
worker named pam who lives in this motel
and even though i mean obviously she's a
sex worker but he sort of has a little
bit of a rapport with her um he'll pay
her extra sometimes like to stay longer
and so he can talk to her because he
doesn't really have anybody else to talk
to like on the outside
and he does have sort of like fantasies
or kind of
you know idol fantasies of maybe maybe
we'll run away together like me and her
we'll go to miami and we'll go to the
beach and they kind of like talk about
that
so as i mentioned this movie is actually
kind of
a slow burn like family drama
more than an outright horror film
but the whole vibe of it is still like
pretty
bleak and like pretty grim
because you know that
while you're watching it this situation
that this family is in
is not sustainable obviously um
you know it's it's just kind of like a
point where
they kind of make mention a couple of
times even though dwight and jesse are
essentially putting their own
their own lives on the line to keep
thomas alive but they say you know he
might die anyway this is apparently
whatever this disease is this vampirism
disease is terminal so they're just
trying to keep him alive and keep him
uh entertained for as long as they can
but obviously they have to kill people
to do it so at some point they might end
up getting caught so obviously there's
that whole situation
but all of them kind of feel trapped i
guess like by their familial duty so
they're all kind of like trapped in this
situation but the thing about it is that
even though dwight is finding it harder
and harder to actually like kill people
to keep thomas alive
at the same time he can't really imagine
like letting his brother die either
because thomas isn't a monster he's
actually as i said he's a little bit
older like an older teenager and stuff
but he's actually very childlike he's
very gentle he's very sweet natured and
it's not
you know you're led to believe that it's
not his fault that he ended up this way
you know and he doesn't like jump on
people and you know and eat them or
anything like that it's just kind of
like he stays in the house he does what
he's told so there's that situation too
so dwight's just sitting there he can't
really square
you know i have to go out and kill these
people with
you know but i also and i don't want to
do that but i also don't want to let
thomas die either because he's my
brother and i love him
now jessie has kind of like a little bit
of a different thing going on because i
kind of feel like after a while like
dwight kind of starts [ __ ] up and
he's just like look i can't do this
anymore and like some people escape and
[ __ ] like that so jesse decides well i'm
gonna have to do this [ __ ] myself she
seems a lot more
cold-blooded not maybe not cold-blooded
but like practical but you can tell that
she only does that because
i mean for the same sense of duty
because thomas is her brother and she is
it's her responsibility to keep him
alive and she's going to do whatever it
takes to do that so it's interesting
like watching it because it's like you
know people that are parents or
something like that like what if
your kid for example like
needed fresh blood to live you know what
would you do to keep your kid alive so
it's just kind of like that whole entire
it's just that kind of dilemma like sort
of played out except it's with older
siblings instead of parents but it's the
same dynamic jessie as i said even
though she is a little bit more
pragmatic in the sense that she's like
look we just have to keep him alive we
can't get like you know we can't get all
sentimental about like killing these
people no one's gonna miss them blah
blah but as i said she just does that
because that's what she tells herself
and she does like actually even though
she's very strict and she doesn't let
thomas go outside or anything like that
she does try to make things nice for him
like i said she does
spend a lot of time homeschooling him
she made up all these games like you
know kind of musical stuff uh you know
they play the organ together and she has
a thing where they celebrate christmas
once a month instead of just once a year
just so he doesn't get bored you know
what i mean
however obviously uh thomas is a person
too
and he's also starting to i mean the
situation is really starting to wear on
him as well because obviously he's like
look i i can't stay in here in this
house like just with you people he wants
to go outside he wants to have friends
his own age you know he wants to have
something like a normal life because
he's like look i'm just stuck in this
house i can't go anywhere and so it's
not even like a life at all
um so that's kind of another place where
this dilemma kind of takes place because
jesse's like well we have to keep you
safe but he's like but i'm not living
you know what i mean so it's that even
though a lot of that is unspoken that's
uh clearly what the conflict is that's
going on
so at some point uh thomas does try to
contact like an outsider like a neighbor
kid and stuff like that and you know
that
that isn't the one thing that like sets
off this series of events but there is
one particular thing or actually it's
not even one particular thing but there
is kind of like a breaking down of the
routine which leads from one event to
another which just makes this situation
more and more untenable like as the
movie goes on uh as i said i'm not going
to spoil the ending because it's a
fairly new movie and it hasn't been on
the streaming services for all that long
but as i said don't go into this
expecting it is a vampire movie
but don't go into it expecting like you
know blade or dracula like you know
anything like a classical traditional
vampire type of story this is much more
like
using vampirism as sort of like a
metaphorical thing to explore
the sacrifices that family members make
the things that they have to do to like
keep their loved ones alive even if
those things are really really in this
case uh really really terrible and
really really evil and like how far
would you go
um if you had a loved one that had that
needed this and would you end up doing
what these siblings did for their
brother so as i said if you like stuff
like this thematically this is similar
to let the right one end it's like a
totally different vibe to that movie
like don't think that it's similar but
thematically it's kind of like explore
some of the same
themes as let the right one in as i said
uh the addiction martin movies like that
if you like vampire movies that are more
like that then you'll probably dig this
one as well um i actually quite liked it
it is quite slow uh it is very bleak it
is very grim
but you guys know i kind of like that
kind of thing so if you like that kind
of thing then this is very easy to watch
i believe it's streaming for free on 2b
it's also on shutter as of this
recording and i'm pretty sure it's also
on amazon prime as well so if that
sounds interesting at all to you then
please check it out and if you've seen
it uh let me know what you thought about
it in the comments and that will do it
for this uh installment of flickers of
fear and i will see you guys on the next
one bye